il a été confronté au juge d'instruction
de 24 février dernier on savait déjà que
la plaignante l'avait été la dernière je
suis venu sur le plateau je vous avais
dit que j'avais eu son avocate qui
m'avait dit que incessamment sous peu ça
devait arriver c'est arrivé l'entretien
a duré cinq heures
il a comment dire il ne reconnaît
toujours pas les faits lui il estime que
le rapport était consenti que y avait
certains rapports probablement musclé
mais qu'en tout cas il y avait
absolument pas de reçus de la plaignante
et il est sorti un petit peu
voilà un petit peu fatigué ça s'est bien
passé ou pas a priori oui maintenant lui
ce qu'ils disent et qu' il a n'a
absolument pas forcé quoi que ce soit il
a c'est un rapport consenti et c'est
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'accord alors
aujourd'hui donc qu'est ce qui va se
passer c'est quoi la suite d un profond
nous on veut pas idéaliser polhenri il
ya une confrontation qui est prévu
d'accord on sait pas quand d'ici
quelques mois deux mois trois mois
d'accord avec la plaignante gilles oui
alors on se demande souvent ici ce qui
va survenir dans cette affaire notamment
si un jour ary abittan était exonéré de
responsabilités
oui j'ai une info ceux déjà sur
l'instruction donc ça a démarré il a été
mis en examen en novembre 2000 21 il y
en a pour 12 à 18 mois d'instruction ça
veut dire que l'instruction va se
terminer au premier semestre 2023 donc
quoi qu'il arrive jusqu'en 2023 ary
abittan ne pourra plus travailler ça
c'est une info ça veut dire que c'est
long ensuite soit il ya un non-lieu soit
il est renvoyé devant une juridiction
pour un procès est bon il risque 15 ans
de prison si jamais un procès on verra
mais ça veut dire de risque quinze ans
par exemple 15 ans de prison mis en
examen pour viol vous confirmez santa fe
et l'instruction peut durer encore plus
longtemps que ça à l'avenir qu'en fait
ce sont des délais qui sont prévues par
la justice mais en réalité une
instruction criminelle ça peut durer des
années d'accord donc ya pas de délais
légaux privé
ça va être nommé la halle durera 18 mois
ça veut dire qu'il ne pourra plus
travailler pendant un long moment alors
il pointe une fois par semaine au
commissariat il respecte totalement son
contrôle judiciaire mais voilà c'est un
contrôle judiciaire assez léger mais
pour le travail franchement y'en à pau
oui clément de longues années il dit que
justement ils pointent tous les toutes
les semaines au commissariat mais
comment il a fait pour partir en
vacances pour noël il avoir le rallye
s'est mise en examen pour suspicion de
viol comment on peut avoir une
dérogation pour en vacances on peut
demander et là ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'il a été mis en examen dont qu'il est
placé sous contrôle judiciaire contrôle
judiciaire ça veut dire qu'il ya des
obligations effectivement de pointe et
de ne pas avoir de contact avec la
victime et divers obligations qui
peuvent lui être imposée par le juge
mais il peut demander effectivement
d'avoir une levée provisoire de
certaines restrictions pour pouvoir
partir en vacances je vous en avais
parlé d'un faux que j'étais venu sur ce
plateau moi j'avais appelé la
journaliste de paris match qui avait
fait la fameuse enquête dont on a
beaucoup parlé à l'époque et c'est vrai
que ce qui se dit aussi c'est que si
c'était paraît habitants mais voilà il
ya des traitements de faveur parfois qui
existent s'était paré habitants il
serait peut-être pas partis en vacances
ils ne répètent pas été à ce qu'il
considère qu'il n'est pas dans le flou
c'est ce que vous êtes et ce que vous
m'aviez dit mais les plans c'est vrai
mais sauf que peut-être qu'un autre
personnage qui serait pas arrivé
habitants n'auraient pas eu ce
traitement de faveur si tu sais ce qui
se dit j'ai une question à vous poser
est-ce qui gît le dit il part il va pas
travailler jusqu'en 2023 farpait 2024
est ce qu'il existe imaginons qu'il soit
innocenté ce qu'il existe des assurances
voilà pour dire la flore est plus tourné
dans deux films pas j'aurais pu faire un
spectacle avec tant de représentations
est ce que c'est possible ou pas faim
alors bon on en avait parlé un peu pas
exactement sur cet angle là avec gilles
la dernière fois à propos des habitants
toujours il ya des assurances qui
peuvent être pris qui sont des
assurances très spécifique avant avant
que ce genre de phénomène ait lieu après
aller revendiquer un spectacle qui n'a
pas eu lieu un film qui ne s'est pas
fait une série dont on a été effacée et
squeeze et non pas ce qu'ils faisaient
avant les voilà en moyenne cheveux et on
voit la série pour attaquer les victimes
il pourra attaquer ont endommagé les
dommages intérêts à caen cessation
calomnieuse si jamais il est déclaré
innocent et ça et ça c'est quoi c'est la
présumée victime qui devrait nous allons
éventuellement mais c'est si l'on sait
qu'il peut il risque jusqu'à 15 ans de
prison et jusqu'à 15 ans de prison donc
là pour le moment il ya une instruction
ça veut dire qu'il ya une enquête qui
est menée par un juge d'instruction qui
peut mener ce qu'on appelle des
commissions rogatoires c'est à dire des
auditions comme ce qu'il a eue là lui il
peut y avoir plusieurs auditions qui
peut demander des expertises
psychiatriques les expertises physiques
différents types d expertise et qui peut
mener également des confrontations
visiblement il va y en avoir une il dira
t on et expertises alors les expertises
ont été il y en a certaines qui
visiblement d'après ce que j'ai vu dans
la presse ont été faites j'imagine que
d'autres vont être demandés et puis on
peut demander des contre-expertises donc
là une instruction ça peut durer très
longtemps car oui mais moi j'aimerais
savoir le réalise quand il ya
confrontation justement entre la
plaignante et arrêts habitants c'est les
avocats qui parle ou c'est eux qui se
parlent et qui se disent des choses
c'est la parole des avocats ils ont le
droit de se parler comment ça se passe
parce que pour la plaignante c'est
peut-être aussi difficile d'être
confronté à l inverse d'ailleurs c'est
vrai et c'est une très bonne question
quand on dit confrontation on imagine
souvent s'il fait d'aligner les bonnes
questions
rosie sens très bien non mais c'est vrai
que la chine souvent confrontation on
imagine l'un en face de l'autre alors ça
se passe pas du tout comme ça on est
dans un bureau devant le juge
d'instruction avec son greffier à côté
donc hélas pour noter ce qui se passe et
on a la partie civile qui est d'un côté
avec son avocat l'autre avocat qui est à
côté et l'autre partie ensuite et les
deux parties s'adresse chacune au juge
mais aucune ne s'adresse pas l'une à
l'autre et être en plus refuser c'est
d'être confronté oui tout à fait on peut
refuser moi je le déconseille
généralement à mes clients parce que
c'est un aveu aussi un aveu
potentiellement nasa peut être pris
comme un aveu de faiblesse disons qu'il
vaut mieux quand même mais ça peut être
très difficile pour les victimes j'étais
en confrontation pour une victime de
violences conjugales ya indians à deux
semaines et c'est vrai que c'est très
bien utile pour la victime oui l'autre
information c'est que là où les
habitants s'est caché pendant des
semaines ils s'étaient isolés dans une
maison à la campagne aujourd'hui ne se
cache plus il sort dans paris à visage
découvert il va au restaurant moi je l'a
perçue au restaurant il ya quelques
semaines il ya plein de gens qui
viennent le voir se prennent des photos
avec lui on a le sentiment qu'il ya un
vrai décalage un vrai fossé entre le
tribunal médiatique qui veut le
condamner à tout prix avant la justice
et les gens qui semblent toujours
l'aimer et qui veulent peut-être laisser
la justice faire son travail plus rien
et ouais a presque guillaume a raison et
je pense que ce que veut ary abittan
c'est peut-être contré ce dont on avait
parlé la dernière fois aussi c'est à
dire l'enquète qui suit son cours et les
éventuels casseroles qui peuvent
remonter on en avait parlé dans
l'article de paris match c'est à dire
des jeunes femmes qu'il aurait croisé et
avec qui ça ce serait plus ou moins bien
passé que ce soit par un comportement un
peu misogyne sexistes voire par des
actes un petit peu répréhensible voir
beaucoup donc ça c'est ce qui va aussi
déterminer beaucoup de choses d'ici à la
confrontation d'une verbaux qu'on a
essayé bien entendu de d'avoir la
plaignante d'avoir des nouvelles et son
avocat dit toujours qu'elle ne veut pas
s'exprimer c'est toujours très cloisonné
pour moment il pour le moment il n'y a
pas d' expression publique de la
plaignante nie d'ailleurs d'interviews
d'arrêt habitants c'est toujours très
verrouillé par le juge et les deux
parties se demande un peu si l'un va
finir par s'exprimer pour le moment rien
géraldine le rallye ce même si la
présomption d'innocence bien sûr il est
quand même mis en examen pour viols et
donc j'imagine qu'en france aujourd'hui
il ya des gens qui sont mis en examen
pour viols des hommes beaucoup j'imagine
des femmes aussi pourquoi pas ils sont
tous en liberté ces gens là ils sont pas
tous en liberté il y en a certains qui
sont en détention provisoire
la question qui se pose quand une
personne est mise en examen elle peut
être renvoyée devant ce qu'on appelle le
juge des libertés et de la détention qui
va déterminer si il la personne en
question présentent un danger pour la
société s'il ya un risque de réitération
des faits si un risque de destruction de
preuves de fuite à l'étranger de
concertation avec d'autres personnes et
dans ce cas là s'il faut l'isoler et
donc la placer en détention provisoire
justement pour éviter ce genre de
problème là le juge des libertés et de
la détention a estimé qu' un contrôle
judiciaire suffisait et qui avait donc
pas de danger particulier notamment au
niveau de la réitération des faits
j'imagine carrie habitants ne doit
potentiellement pas avoir eu de contact
avec la vie une jurisprudence déjà un
dossier un peu similaire vous avez voir
qui s'est soldée par la cie
s'est soldée par un non-lieu s'est soldé
par quoi ça sert sa mère des combats il
a été condamné à combien de temps deux
exemples 1 voilà une personne voilà le
nombre d'acquis aurait fait qui aurait
été incarné même pour les mêmes faits
car et habitants
elle a été incarcérée combien de temps
moi j'ai pas de cas similaires parce
qu'on est tous les cas sont différents
en réalité tous les on al'impression on
parle souvent de cas de viols et de cas
d'agressions etc mais en réalité pour
pour être vraiment dans la pratique tous
les dossiers sont différents et il ya
des éléments différents à chaque fois et
parfois on a des coups de théâtre dans
le cadre d'une instruction voire même
parfois aux assises il arrive qu'on ait
des coûts théâtre et j'ai déjà eu le cas
plusieurs fois
donc il n'y a pas vraiment de règles là
l'instruction pourra se soldait soit par
un non lieu soit pour un renvoi en cour
d'assises soit par une
correctionnalisation est donc un renvoi
devant le tribunal correctionnel et donc
non pas ce serait non saint leu le crime
de viol serait alors transformé
non-parents crime mais se transformer en
délit